hey guys we're off to Prague today are
you talking to the camera oh my goodness
person planning with yesterday it was so
beautiful it was a really long day I'm
not sure if it's like a German tradition
but like I don't know it was like the
longest wedding ever but it was so
beautiful everything was like perfect it
was unbelievable it was awesome isn't a
castle it was honestly like the coolest
thing ever
my hotel it's been great
after Prague basically run a car first
new hotel room we're in Prague I'm so
excited so I decided to Google Apple
Store and I saw that there is one of the
largest private collections of Apple
when Joseph's million to be fair as I
was looking at the second as I was
saying one of the largest private
collections of Apple items in one room
so I'm super excited about it much of
anybody else in our party is but girl I
am do you know what the second largest
is huh your house no this is like old
things like everything they even have an
Apple visa oh wow I actually just
started crying because I was at the web
site and I was just looking through all
of the saw that they have and they have
a cafe it's called Stephens food so it's
like stuff that Steve Jobs would eat
it's all vegetarian I can't even
understand anything this website is
saying can we go for eight minutes away
I'm wasting precious data using my
Google Maps trust me it's gonna be the
coolest thing you've seen ever okay
ready
Oh God we just can't get there fast
enough
we are two minutes away who is away
we turn this corner we're gonna be at
the Apple Store Museum not sore we're
almost here I saw this on Google Maps I
see it you see three there holy ground
oh I open your eyes
I am unable to control how happy I am
right now glasses
come on
you wanna see my got my heart
that was by far the coolest thing that
I've ever seen if you guys are ever in
Prague please go to the Apple Museum
because it is so incredible when they
said it the largest collection of Apple
items ever everything is in pristine
condition it was absolutely perfect they
said you couldn't take pictures or to
video so I only filmed a little bit
because I didn't want to break the rules
but I had to I mean this was like
basically a dream come true I can't
stress to you enough how incredible it
was city guys are ever here in Prague go
to the Apple museum and also get a
churro ice cream which we're gonna do
right now after we get pizza
pizza party
we're so excited we're getting at their
called treadlow something with ice cream
kind of like a churro filled delicious
treat to to look for low your the log
treadlow doesn't matter
it's called delicious in my book
weird because we're like walking in the
move the street yet it's a road but it
feels like a sidewalk but yet it's a
street and then a car just comes and
you're like oh sorry I should get
something about the Apple museum it was
incredible guys
just incredible
we are off to visit a castle I had to
put some eye patches on because my eyes
were very puffy from random sleep
schedules I don't even know what time it
is where we are I do know that it's time
to go and I'm late
like always
it's a really amazing birthday they've
only first walked in and it was one of
the best I've seen you my favorite time
of day
kind of saying there's a guinea pig huh
can we get up and just get our food or
water clear off the prague castle and
rumor has it there's a Starbucks there
so this is great news for all parties
involved it seemed like we're going
awfully far away from it to get to it
it's way back there
we're trying to figure out where to park
yeah let's take a peek oh look we don't
know where to park we're trying to go
see the castle things aren't working out
so well can you park there we got cars
there this is all blue
some issues things are not clear to us
well we found a place we don't know if
we can actually park there or not
there's just a lot of questions that we
have and a lot of answers that we don't
have
the church that you'll see has mass at
7:00 a.m. and the rest of the day it's a
Taurus
I learned that Puma sniping the tour
guides info
we're gonna believe what we spotted we
found a familiar sign Starbucks
downstairs 80 seats Terrace restaurants
beautiful view
I'm happy Sam
we haven't go to see the castle yet
that's cool we're gonna go doesn't be
right there's Wi-Fi here
we've now made it into the castle and we
just witnessed the changing of the
guards it was actually so hot outside
that my camera started overheating so I
had to shut it off
well that concludes our little tour here
at the castle now we have to just hope
and pray that our car is still there and
didn't get to boot or ticketed I didn't
wanna ruin Jenna's vlog again because
she just yelled at me but I wanted to
let her know that there was grilled
cheese so I think that's the car is it
here it is this is great news
let's crank this Wow war back two dozen
you can drive so fast here it's beyond
incredible like beef this car just
passed us up going probably like 200
miles an hour
and we were here like 24 hours ago back
address an airport and now jet and I are
going to be getting a cab to our hotel
somewhere in Dresden and you guys are
going back to Pennsylvania that where
you guys are going okay okay we made it
back safely and another hotel we are at
oh cool oh my god Disney see you guys
tomorrow
unless we do stuff tonight here I don't
know whatever leave me alone let me
alone
but ask me so many questions I have been
taking some photos and video Kristen
today so she has a photographer coming
later